In the video about the molecular structure of DNA
we saw that DNA consists of two chains,
the backbone of which
is composed of phosphate -
I will use different colors.
From a phosphate group and sugar.
We have a phosphate group.
And sugar (in the backbone of the molecule).
Here we have a phosphate group.
And sugar.
I can draw the chain in this way.
We have phosphate and sugar.
I'll draw all the phosphates in advance.
So let's see the phosphates on this side
and then the sugars.
We see the same thing on the other circuit.
We have
phosphate and sugar,
then another phosphate and other sugar,
then another phosphate.
I will also surround the sugars.
We have sugar here
and here.
The other circuit will look the same way.
I'll paint the phosphates.
I only show them.
We have phosphates, then we draw the sugars
between phosphates.
What connects them can be likened to
the steps of the ladder.
The steps are the complementary nitrogen bases.
We call them nitrogen bases because -
actually forgot to talk about it in the previous videos,
because these nitrogen atoms are very electronegative
and can also take on hydrogen protons.
They have an additional free e-pair.
Nitrogen atoms have an additional free pair,
which, under appropriate conditions,
can also attract more hydrogen protons.
Many people ask,
"Once we have nitrogen bases here,"
"why DNA is called acid?"
"Why is it called acid?"
First, the basic properties
the nitrogen bases are largely offset
from bases forming
hydrogen bonds with each other.
This is how they form
the stairs of the ladder,
when the complementary nitrogen bases
form hydrogen bonds with each other.
But the more important reason why we call DNA acid,
are the phosphate groups. When protonated, they are acidic.
The reason to paint them deprotonated is,
that they are so acidic that if they are placed
in neutral solution, will be deprotonated.
This is the form that is more likely
to find in the core of a real cell.
The deprotonated form of DNA.
Phosphate groups are considered acidic.
If I want to draw a cleaner phosphate group,
I talked about this in the previous video,
I will have to protonate it and it will not
to put the negative charge here.
This is a review from the previous video.
Let's go on
forward.
Draw the bases of nitrogen.
Here we have thymine.
I will color the finish in this green color.
This is a thymin here.
This is related to thymine.
And the complementary nitrogen base
thymine is adenine.
Who will --
to see, end my colors.
Let's see. Adenine.
I will paint it in orange,
because it contains so much nitrogen.
In fact, it must also include this hydrogen here.
This is adenine here.
They have hydrogen bonds
with each other.
Because they have partially negative and positive charges
at both ends, attracted to each other.
Now let's go downstairs.
What is happening?
Let's see --
Now the colors are really over.
This nitrogen base is cytosine.
This nitrogen base here is cytosine.
And it connects with guanine.
It is associated with guanine.
I will draw a guanine in this color.
They are connected.
We have guanin here.
We saw this even in the introductory video about DNA.
Now you can say, "Oh, look, these two chains"
"look parallel to one another."
And in some ways it is.
But there may be another
an interesting thing you noticed -
the direction in which the chains are oriented.
I guess this is the best way to say it.
This is especially noticeable when we concentrate on sugars.
Notice the sugars here, the deoxyribosides
or portions of the nucleotides resulting from deoxyribose.
You see the oxygen atoms at the top,
at the top of these five-membered rings.
Oxygen is on top.
Well, on this side, the oxygen is below.
So, the chains are oriented in different directions.
Here the oxygen points upwards,
here the oxygen points down.
And to make it a little clearer,
we can number the carbon atoms,
to think about the direction
and use the sequential numbers of carbon atoms,
to describe the different directions.
To number the carbon atoms.
These two molecules are ribose,
we saw them in the video about the molecular structure of DNA.
When we talk about DNA,
we are talking about deoxyribose.
Instead of having a hydroxyl group,
connected to carbon atom number two, the deoxyribose has hydrogen.
Instead of a hydroxyl group,
Let's number them.
This is a carbon atom,
we begin with the carbonyl group.
Let me make it in a different color.
This is a carbon atom a primacy.
I number them starting from the carbonyl group.
One example (1 '). Two prim.
Three prim. Four Prix.
Five Prim.
When we look at the cyclic shape,
it is a carbon atom a primacy.
This is two examples.
This is three prim.
This is four prim.
This is five prim.
If we have to number them
of this scheme here,
in the DNA molecule,
this is a primacy.
This is a carbon atom two primes.
This is the carbon atom three primes.
This is the carbon atom four primes.
And this is the carbon atom five prim.
It is important to think
for the phosphate group, it participates in the
phosphodiester bonds.
Phosphodiester bonds
allow the individual parts of the DNA backbone to bind.
After phosphate, we have a carbon atom five
and then through sugar, we come to a carbon atom three primes.
Then we get to another phosphate.
Then we have a carbon atom five.
I will note that this is carbon atom five.
Then we come to a carbon atom three primes.
And this stems only from the numbering of carbon atoms,
starting from carbon atom number one.
When in open form,
it is part of a carbonyl group.
But you see we're starting at five.
We start with phosphate, five primes, three primes,
phosphate, five, three, phosphate.
We can describe the orientation of this circuit,
"Hey, we're going in the direction
"from five to three,"
We can say the direction
of the left chain is
from five to three.
And what about the right chain?
Let's number the carbon atoms again.
This is a carbon atom a primacy.
Now this in comparison with that
is headed down, this chain is inverted.
Thus, a favor. Two prim.
Three prim. Four Prix.
Five Prim.
I can do it here too.
Carbon atom one preference. Carbon atom two prim.
Carbon atom three exemplified.
Carbon atom four by. Carbon atom 5 exempt.
Here we go from phosphate to
three primes, five primes, phosphate.
Three primes, five primes, phosphate.
The way sugars are oriented,
when we go from top to bottom
it is
from three to five.
The chain on the right side is oriented
We could draw an arrow
from five to three,
like this.
It can be said that these circuits are parallel,
but since
are directed in different directions,
although they are parallel,
we call the structure of DNA - antiparallel.
It is
antiparallel structure of DNA.
These two chains are complementary.
They are defined from one another.
Timin binds to adenine,
cytosine - with guanine.
They are attracted to one another
and are linked via hydrogen bonds.
But the two spine,
are directed in opposite directions.
Another interesting topic for reflection,
when we talk about the structure of DNA,
is how these things are formed?
How do they know they should be oriented in this way?
An important role is played by the fact that
phosphate groups are negative.
The parts they have
negative charge,
will try to get as far as possible
from each other.
Then they continue to orient themselves
and to distract themselves.
And they are long.
These molecules are very, very, very, very long.
In the introductory video about DNA
we talk about how long chromosomes are
how many base pairs we have.
These are long molecules.
So all these phosphate groups on each of the chains,
want to move away from each other.
And those parts want to get closer
because of hydrogen bonds.
Thus, this ladder-like structure is obtained.
DNA is a fascinating molecule,
we can talk about it for days.
It is disturbing
how huge a role it plays in determining who we are.
I hope this video has given you a better idea
about what is DNA molecule molecular, molecular -
I can not say it. At the molecular level.